[Music]
all right tonight we're gonna go through
step by step we're gonna explain how the
fix was in with every single scandal
involving the Clintons here's everything
you need to know when it comes to
America's most corrupt political family
no rules apply no laws exist ethics do
not matter Hillary Clinton rigged the
Democratic primary to stop Bernie
Sanders she robbed him blind the fix was
in Hillary Clinton actually colluded
with Russia by paying you know millions
of millions of dollars for that fake
news dossier Russian propaganda Russian
collusion to smear Donald Trump and she
tried to influence you the American
people to swing the election with those
lies the fix was it James Comey changed
the announcement about Clinton's private
email server even after her team deleted
33,000 subpoenaed emails destroyed some
of them by using acid-wash known as
bleach pit and even taking a hammer to
BlackBerry's the fix was in
Bill Clinton met with former attorney
general Loretta Lynch on tarmac in an
airport for 40 minutes only days before
commis decision are we really to believe
all they talked about was their
grandkids the fix was in
then there's the corrupt uranium one
deal millions of dollars pour into the
Clinton Foundation and Bill and
Hillary's pocket she's the Secretary of
State she approved this agreement one of
nine people and of course all while Bill
is doubling a speaking fees in Moscow
and by the way trying to meet with
nuclear officials in Russia and he did
meet with Vladimir Putin and there's
also the massive plot that the FBI
uncovered one year before that deal was
approved which includes bribery
extortion money laundering kickbacks
racketeering
key members of the Obama administration
knew this was happening including Muller
and Eric Holder yet they decided to give
20% of America's uranium to Russia and
to Putin the fix was it even Lindsey
Graham is now calling for a special
counsel to be appointed to investigate
Clinton actually wants two special
counsels all these cases prove the
Clintons think they are above
law and they are protected by Democrats
and a colluding media but tonight one
Democrat is calling them out former
interim DNC chair Donna Brazile
continues to expose this corrupt Clinton
political machine on a level nobody ever
knew existed
Hillary rigged stole the Democratic
primary
stole the Democratic nomination and
Donna Brazile is continuing to tell her
story after she wrote an article for
Politico magazine last week entitled
inside Hillary Clinton's secret take
over the DNC and she explained how it
was all rigged and she found evidence
Hillary quote rigged the DNC cheated
Bernie Sanders and his supporters out of
the nomination it was so bad Donna
Brazile agonized when she had to tell
Bernie the truth she also revealed that
there was a secret agreement between the
Clinton campaign and the DNC it gave
Hillary Clinton and her campaign total
control of the DNC's finances strategy
personnel decisions budgeting data
analytics and mailings think about this
for a minute
Hillary Clinton former first lady of
Arkansas and the United States former
senator stole a primary election all of
you who voted for Bernie Sanders you
were cheated everybody disenfranchised
she sold you out there are also new
parts of Donna Brazil's book that are
coming out like how she considered
trying to replace Hillary Clinton with
Joe Biden as the party's nominee
remember when Hillary collapsed at the
9/11 memorial we played it a lot o
Brazil also writes that the Clinton
campaign treated her like crap by
writing that she told Clinton's team
quote you all keep whipping me and
whipping me and you never give me any
money and or any way to do my job I'm
not going to be your whipping girl
predictably Democrats are lashing out at
Donna Brazile for telling the truth and
blowing the whistle on Clinton
corruption watch this I think anybody
who suggests that the DNC has the power
to rig an election when I was DNC chair
I knew Katie what we did didn't
influence ten votes I've find it hard to
believe anybody can cite anything
that may have rigged the primary
elections in fillory Clinton's favor I
have great respect for Donna
consider a friend she's done a lot for
the Democratic Party to charge that
Hillary Clinton was somehow
incapacitated is quite frankly ludicrous
in campaign that Brazil fell for Russian
propaganda I don't know what Donna
Brazile fell for when I hear the word
rigged let's let's be very clear
Hillary Clinton won the Democratic
primary by four million votes
demet the Democratic National Committee
does not run elections for primaries of
their allegations she's making there
simply isn't true I would hope that
there's another side to this story but
that again that's neither here nor there
it's almost a waste of time nobody cares
nobody cares let's listen to Donna
Brazile one more nobody cares this week
nobody cares about what developers emma
has said in a book governor wants a
nobody you don't think anybody cares
about her story nobody cares really
governor
nobody cares she stole an election you
know and I know that's a lie and by the
way the liberal mainstream media oh the
same people that colluded with Hillary
Clinton the same people that are
basically an extension of the Democratic
National Committee and they're talking
points every day that don't have an
original thought in their head and
they're a bunch of sheep that apologized
constantly for the Democrats well now
they're apoplectic what's this to go
back over this now when they're trying
to win congressional races and trying to
get ready for 18 seems to me to be
beyond counterproductive I've gotten
emails from Democrats i passionate
democrats who say they feel betrayed by
all this any regrets you think this
helps for the book to come out my issue
is not that she's speaking out and for
my shoes the fact that she's been wrong
I think if I'd done half the things that
she admits to in these excerpts I'm not
sure I would be telling folks
all right thankfully Brazil is not gonna
be pressured she's signaling she's not
going to be silenced by an avalanche of
left wing attacks watch this George for
those who are telling me to shut up they
told Hillary that a couple of months ago
you know what I tell them go to hell I'm
gonna tell my story good for her also
tonight a smoking gun bombshell report
from the hills John Solomon now an early
draft of James Comey is now infamous
announcement about
the Clinton email investigation actually
accused Hillary of being grossly
negligent okay understand those words
are precise and specific the exact
standard which means she broke the law
and John Solomon obtained a copy of a
letter that Senator Chuck Grassley sent
to the FBI which contains the key
sentences found in the draft memo it
says quote there is evidence to support
a conclusion that Secretary Clinton and
others used the private email server in
a manner that was grossly negligent with
respect to the handling of classified
information and material and another
part of the memo says quote similarly
the sheer volume of information that was
properly classified as secret at the
time it was discussed on email that is
excluding the up classified emails
supports the inference that the
participants were grossly negligent in
their handling of that information now
those words are key they were later than
edited out and replaced with the term
extremely careless at the time I told
you there's no difference even though he
explained that Clinton had secret top
secret special access program classified
information on an email server stored in
the basement of a mom-and-pop shop which
by the way we now know five separate
intelligence agencies countries that
don't like us were able to hack into and
a source also told John Solomon that
three other people were involved in
helping draft and then edit out of the
legal realm
call me statement about Clinton now they
are deputy director Andrew McCabe now
he's been under fire ever since the Wall
Street Journal reported that a political
action committee run by yes Virginia
governor I don't care about the rule of
law Terry McAuliffe had deep ties to the
Clintons they donated a half a million
dollars to the state Senate campaign of
McCabe's wife Jill and she also got
another two hundred thousand dollars
from the Virginia Democratic Party for a
state race this is unheard of and late
last week we learned from Judicial Watch
that Andrew McCabe did not recuse
himself from the Clinton server
investigation until just days before the
election there's also more tonight the
di general counsel James Baker he was
also involved
investigative reporter Sarah Carter
reported back in July that Baker was
being investigated for leaking
classified information in the press and
the third person who helped call me was
his former chief of staff now John
Solomon's report also notes that it was
not clear who recommended making the
crucial change in wording but that the
Senate will likely demand those answers
good it's about time we have been saying
for over a year
call me the Obama Justice Department
were protecting Hillary Clinton for laws
she broke that we'd be put in jail for
this revelation tonight offers up even
more incontrovertible evidence call Me's
original news conference never made any
sense because he literally explained how
Clinton broke the law for 13 and a half
minutes but then he stopped short of
recommending charges by claiming she was
extremely careless instead of grossly
negligent a huge legal distinction take
a look at the side of your screen it's a
list that our friend and colleague Fox
News legal analyst Gregg Jarrett put
together for us tonight showing the laws
that Clinton violated with the private
email server we go to jail for this call
me top FBI officials knew Clinton
engaged in criminal conduct otherwise
they wouldn't have accused her of gross
negligence but then something happened
the million-dollar question is what and
remember one other thing
remember Comey made his decision well
before he ever talked to the main people
involved he had already concluded before
he investigated what the outcome would
be remember he refused to testify did
testify under oath the former attorney
general were a little Loretta Lynch
remembers she pressured pressured call
me to call the investigation which was
an investigation a matter and then he
complied and we also know that Comey
decided to not recommend charges against
Clinton months before interviewing the
key witnesses in the case including
Hillary you can't decide before doing
the investigation that is why in
addition to Congress the Department of
Justice needs to open an investigation
into how the FBI and the Obama
administration handled the Clinton case
where obvious law breaking took place
cannot in this country have a two-tier
justice system that's not how this
country works or is supposed to work
also tonight a source is telling Fox
News our own catherine herridge that the
House Intelligence Committee is now
asking Fusion GPS that's the company
behind the fake phony anti-trump Russian
dossier to turn over records that
allegedly show payments to journalists
to publish stories Wow
you talk about first Russia propaganda
Hillary the DNC that she rent she paid
for it all and then of course the group
that used it now they're saying hey
let's pay the journalists now keep in
mind the same company that they used to
funnel ten million dollars or more
through a third party lawyer to create
the dossier that used Russian sources to
smear the president and try and
influence the American people with phony
Russian information to steal an election
and on the issue of so-called Trump
Russia collusion tonight yet another
prominent Democrat forced to admit a
year later she has seen nothing to
indicate there was any collusion between
Donald Trump and the Russians here's
Democrat senator liberal leftist Dianne
Feinstein have you seen any evidence
that this dirt these emails were ever
given to the Trump campaign not so far
not so far have you ever seen have you
seen any communications that suggested
that the Trump campaign wanted them to
release them through a different means
because obviously they were ultimately
released by wiki house I have not if the
Democrats and the left-wing media in
this country cared even a little bit
about the truth then they would stop
spreading lies about President Trump and
now they should focus on real Russia
collusion real crime real evidence real
impropriety and finally tonight our
hearts our prayers go out to the people
in Sutherland Springs Texas their
unimaginable pain and suffering after a
madman attacked a church yesterday
killing 26 people including young
children injuring 20 others this is it
beyond tragic it the Democrats sadly
members of the mainstream media what
within hours they're racing to
politicize this tragedy call for more
gun control
trol now think about this for a second
people are still in the hospital others
haven't even been laid to rest all they
care about is politics
and what's ironic is these are the same
people who are exploiting this tragedy
that they never talked about Chicago I
have some information about Chicago from
this weekend I've been saying it for
years we scroll the names of the
thousands killed because the media
ignored it and even then President Obama
ignored an 18,000 shootings in Chicago
in his last six years really 3,000 dead
now 30 people were shot this weekend it
has been almost 600 homicides this year
in Chicago we'll talk about all of this
later in the program here first